Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Hungarian drama film
called “White God”. Watch out and take care!
Lili is a thirteen-year-old girl living in
Hungary. She has a mixed-breed dog named
Hagen. Since Lili’s parents are divorced,
she hardly gets along with either of them. The
only creature she is close to is her pet dog.
At the beginning of the movie, she plays with the
dog in a park while her mother watches them. She
is planning to move to the United States, leaving
Lili to live with her father Daniel permanently.
Daniel works in a slaughterhouse and hasn’t
met Lili since she was three years old. He is
surprised that she has brought the dog with her
because his apartment is too small to hold one.
He is also not fond of pets in general but has to
compromise because of his daughter. When they get
to the building, Daniel’s landlady tells him
that pets are not allowed in the apartment.
He quietly says that he will get rid of
it in a few days. Even during dinner,
Lili disobeys her father, feeding Hagen homemade
food. They have to squeeze in the same room
because of the size of the apartment. The dog
has separation anxiety and cannot sleep alone
but Daniel still locks him in the bathroom. He
cries for a long time, not letting anyone sleep.
At last, Lili goes to him and plays Franz Liszt's
"Hungarian Rhapsody No. 2" on her trumpet. The
dog calms down after listening to the tune and
Lili sleeps in the bathtub for the night.
The next morning, they are woken up by someone
ringing their doorbell. A man from canine control
informs them of a complaint they received about
their dog howling at night. At first, Daniel tries
to hide the fact that they own a pet but the guy
happens to see Hagen in the apartment. Daniel is
told to pay a large "mongrel" fee imposed by the
Hungarian government because Hagen is a mixed
breed. He is strictly against paying money to keep
the dog he doesn’t even want in the first place.
That day, Lili takes Hagen to her music
class because her father won’t let him alone
in the house. Since no pets are allowed in the
class, she hides him inside a cabinet used to
store instruments. However, when the music
starts to play, a scared Hagen runs outside.
Lili’s music teacher asks her to send the dog
away and stay in the classroom but she disobeys
him and walks out. The two are walking through
the street when Daniel stops them, furious at
the fact that he was called by her music teacher.
He has decided to get rid of the dog at any cost.
He asks Lili to give him to the dog shelter but
she stays adamant about keeping him with her.
Having had enough of her stubbornness,
he kicks the dog out of the car.
Lili cries and asks the dog to return but Daniel
forces her inside and drives away. The poor dog
chases them, not wanting to let go of his master
but he cannot keep up with the speeding car. For
the next few hours, he waits in the street for
Lili, but she never returns. At home, Lili wakes
up in the middle of the night and gets ready to go
to Hagen but she is found by her father who forces
her back to sleep. Hagen wakes up after spending
the night under a bridge. He looks around for
food and finds a dead animal by the side of the
road. After contemplating if he should eat it,
he decides against it. Following that, he reaches
a butcher shop and looks at the meat longingly. A
white stray dog catches his attention who he
follows and ends up in the back of the shop.
Several stray dogs are eating the leftovers but
they bark at Hagen when he tries to get a bite.
This attracts the butcher who chases them
away. A naive Hagen stays put in his place,
making the butcher even more furious. He is
about to attack the poor dog with a knife
but is distracted by the white dog at the right
time. Taking the opportunity, both dogs run away
and reach a puddle where all of the stray dogs
of the area have gathered to drink water.
However, they are soon approached by workers
from animal control who catch them and put
them in cages. Hagen and his friend manage to
run away while being followed. He is chased
through the streets and eventually saved by
a homeless person. After the workers leave,
the man forcefully ties a rope around his neck
and keeps him as his pet. In the meantime,
Daniel takes Lili back to her music class and
makes her apologize to the teacher for yesterday.
After the class, she secretly goes to the street
where they had left the dog the previous day. She
looks for him all around the neighborhood
but to no avail. She also posts posters
of the missing dog everywhere she can. Later at
night, the homeless man sells Hagen to a dealer.
He is chained with his kind in the back of a
shop. The next morning, a client named Szabolcs
comes looking to buy a dog for dog fighting
competitions. The dealer claims Hagen won’t
be good for fighting because he is a lapdog
but Szabolcs buys him anyway. Hagen is given a
sleeping pill which makes him pass out. Following
that, Szabolcs brings him to his house and gives
him a mixture of protein powder. To make him more
aggressive, Szabolcs beats him regularly. He is
mostly starved and caged the entire day. The only
time he is let out is when Szabolcs trains him.
If he doesn’t do as told, he is beaten brutally.
The dog’s life has changed for the worse.
Szabolcs’s training technique gets tougher every
day. Hagen is no longer the gentle dog he used
to be, he eventually turns very aggressive, ready
to be let into the battlefield. In the meantime,
Lili continues her search for him. She goes
to a dog shelter and asks its owner about him.
She is told that he might have been hit by a car
or died in a street fight. Her day gets worse when
her bicycle gets stolen from outside the shelter.
That night, Hagen is brought to the fighting
ground by his master. The rules of the match are
simple; for a dog to win, the other one has to
die. People bet on them and earn a lot of money.
When Szabolcs brings Hagen in, everyone assumes
that he is going to lose. They even tell Szabolcs
he could have done better but the guy is confident
about his training. The match between Hagen and a
rottweiler starts. After a fierce fight, both are
left bloodied and injured, but at last, Hagen gets
a tight grip on his opponent and wins the match.
Impressed by his skills, a dog dealer
approaches Szabolcs wanting to buy him.
When Szabolcs refuses, they get into an argument.
Amidst it, the lights go off and Hagen takes
the opportunity to run away. He runs the entire
night, as far as he can from the dog dealers.
Lili, on the other hand, is running
home after her bicycle was stolen.
She meets a friend from her music class named
Peter. He is about to go to a high school party
which she asks to join. At first, he is reluctant
about bringing her, but he figures she can be used
to carry drugs to the party without being
caught. He makes her hide some pills in her
pocket which she sneaks into the party. Everyone
there is way older than her but Lili doesn’t care.
She sits in a corner and watches everyone dance.
By the end of the night, she falls asleep on the
floor. The next morning, the party is raided by
the police. When Lili is found with drugs, she is
taken to the police station. Thankfully, her tests
come out negative so she is allowed to return home
with her father. Daniel cries for the first time
in years after seeing his daughter well and alive.
He had been worried to death the previous night.
He apologizes to her for taking Hagen away from
her and promises to buy her a new dog. Lili
forgives her father and reconciles with him,
after which, they return home happily. Meanwhile,
Hagen reaches the puddle the next morning and
reunites with his friend, the white dog. They are
together playing by a river when the people from
animal control take them away and put them in a
shelter. Hagen is injured because of the fight
and is treated for it. He is put in a cage with
hundreds of other stray dogs and given food.
While most of the dogs devour it, he doesn’t
even look at the food. The following day,
people come to the shelter to adopt the dogs of
their choice. A girl seems to like Hagen but he
barks at her and is aggressive to the workers.
The owner asks him to be put down. Somewhere else,
Lili is playing the trumpet at a concert with her
orchestra. Daniel is in the audience to cheer for
his daughter. Hagen is about to be thrown in
a cage with the other dogs when he attacks
the dog handler. He grows aggressive and bites
the man on his neck, killing him eventually.
The other dogs follow his lead and rush out of
the cage. Since Hagen is the one to free them,
they make him the leader of the pack. The owner
of the shelter tries to stop him but he pushes
her aside and escapes with the others. They
run through the city, ensuing chaos all around.
People run away to save their lives as the dogs
begin to attack everyone in their way. Eventually,
the dogs also reach the concert that Lili is
playing in. They surround it from all the sides
making the audience barricade themselves within
the auditorium for safety. The performance stops
as everyone starts to panic. Lili senses that
Hagen is also with them and runs outside despite
Peter warning her not to. A stranger tells Lili
and Peter to not go downstairs because the entire
city is in lockdown but they do not listen.
At last, she cycles down the empty streets trying
to find Hagen, believing that she can stop the
havoc. Eventually, a pack of dogs chases behind
her. She falls to the ground but they ignore her
as if they are on a mission. It turns out that
Hagen is leading them to all the people who have
hurt him in the past. First, he finds Szabolcs
and approaches him. Soon, he is joined by his pack
who attack him, leaving a bloody mess behind. When
Lili gets to the location, they have already left.
A policeman finds her and puts her in the car.
However, she escapes and cycles away looking for
Hagen yet again. She reaches a meat shop and finds
the butcher dead on the floor. He was the same guy
who had tried to kill Hagen earlier in the movie.
She calls Daniel and asks him to stay inside at
any cost. He, on the other hand, is worried about
her safety. Somewhere else, the police force
shoots and kills several dogs but more of them
keep on coming. The pack goes to the dealer who
had sold Hagen in the market and kills him as
well. Now, their last target is Daniel. Lili
cycles back to her home and finds the landlady
dead. She freaks out and runs to her apartment,
finally realizing what Hagen is trying to do.
Knowing that her father’s life is also in
danger, she runs back to the auditorium.
Daniel sees her safe and is relieved. However,
Lili is soon approached by Hagen who appears
to have forgotten her after everything he
has been through. As he growls at Lili,
his army joins him. They are about to attack
her when Daniel comes forward with a blowtorch
to distract them and save his daughter. When
they still do not calm down, Lili plays Franz
Liszt's "Hungarian Rhapsody No. 2" on her trumpet.
Hagen finally remembers her because of the tune.
He calms down and the pack follows his lead. They
all lay on the ground, listening to her play.
Daniel is shocked and relieved at the fact she is
safe. At last, she also lays on the ground with
the dogs. The movie ends as Daniel joins them.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.